hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to when
people talk about the best Batman movie
what usually comes to mind ah but
seriously Dark Knight Batman 89 and yeah
usually just those two but when it comes
to the best representation of Batman as
a whole there's one that everybody
always overlooks the animated one now
I'm not talking about the animated
series or the dozens of DVD releases I'm
talking about the hand-drawn theatrical
release that didn't do well at the box
office but more and more people are
discovering every year that is Batman
mask of the phantasm released in 1993
phantasm was trying to cash in on the
rise and success of Batman the Animated
Series taking place in the same universe
it had the same voice actors writers
animation team except on a cinematic
level it was a critical hit and as
mentioned before is gaining a following
as possibly the best Batman movie there
is but if that's the case how come it's
gotten so little attention not a ton of
people talk about at least not on the
level of the other Batman films and
there's not even a blu-ray release of it
yeah that's right the Schumacher films
got a blu-ray release but the movie with
what some consider the best Batman best
Joker and best modern-day storytellers
of the classic characters doesn't why is
this swept under the rug while movies
like Dark Knight were declared the best
Batman flick even before it was released
the better understand let's take a short
spoiler free look at the story a
mysterious villain known as the phantasm
is killing off what appears to be random
gangsters yeah killing as in this movie
is PG when PG actually meant something
people believe it's Batman is from a
distance it seems to look like him and
thus it's up to our hero to find out
who's behind these murders while also
outrunning the police on top of that an
old flame named andreia comes back into
his life as a seemed she was his first
love after the loss of his parents this
gives some insight of his transformation
into Batman as he's tortured by the fact
that for the first time he's actually
happy and feels as human as he's ever
felt since the murder of his parents as
with all gothic stories though it
doesn't end
leaving the two bitter at each other
despite the fact that each one knows
they're hiding information that the
other could use to make things worse one
of the gangsters brings in the Joker to
try and take Batman or whoever is behind
this murder spray down before his life
is next
it's a 4-way clash between Batman the
phantasm
the Joker and the police all trying to
see who can take out the other first
while solving this complicated mystery
sounds promising but what makes it
particularly special in comparison to
the other Batman and on top of that what
separates it from just being an extended
episode of the animated series first of
all the budget is certainly higher as
wonderful as the animation was on the TV
show you can tell there's a lot more
focus and effort on this project the
characters look more solid and
three-dimensional but still lend
themselves to exaggerated designs
allowing for greater expressions they
also stay true to their form as well at
this time every anime a film was putting
CG everywhere it was new and looked cool
but sometimes they put it in places
where it didn't belong this movie knew
the technology at the time will look
good with their Art Deco style so they
just used it for the opening credits
which adds a little something different
but doesn't distract from anything if
they tried to have Batman in the
phantasm fight in an animated City you
would look a lot like the animated
spider-man cartoon at the time just kind
of awkward and phony this film knew to
keep to its roots and stay and draw on
and much like the show it doesn't shy
away from its dark style with harsh
shadows grim colors and a lot of
enjoyable white work but ok Batman and
Robin had pretty colors what makes it a
particularly good film because the focus
is where any great Batman story should
be on the screwed-up psyche of our
characters before Batman Begins there
was really no cinematic look at Bruce
Wayne's transformation into Batman now
there's nothing wrong with that as you
can argue it's more powerful what you
don't see as opposed to what you do but
this is one that goes into an element
that's never really been explored Bruce
Wayne if he found happiness the death of
his parents is so strong with him that
even when he finds love he feels guilty
he pleads on their tombstones
forgiveness like being happy is some
sort of crime all he's known is law so
when he finally finds something it
throws him off and he doesn't know how
to react to it
please I need it to be different men
know I made a promise but I didn't see
this coming it didn't count on being
happy it's a pretty damn good
psychological analysis without being
well literal psychological analysis you
see their morals the only as good as the
world allows them to be yes yes you took
a psych class shut up well that's all
great from persuade me but what about
Batman the character everybody wants to
see well the advantage of this movie is
that while it is a continuation of the
show you can catch on even if you
haven't watched it if you're failing the
cartoon you'll laugh even harder at
Batman and the Joker's history but if
you're not you can still follow who he
is and what their connection is as well
as all these characters but the clever
is advantage that the animated series
was is that it encompassed practically
everything that was Batman from the
comics to the Burton movies to even a
little bit of the Adam West show it was
a hodgepodge of everything the character
has been in the past
everybody could recognize something from
a version of Batman they grew up with
but it also somehow still managed to be
its own unique entity as well even
creating new characters that have now
become regulars in the lore the movie
works in the same way it works as a dark
journey into a character psyche but it
also works as comic-book camp it has
serious discussions and tough questions
but it also has death traps and rocket
packs it's not ashamed to be a comic
book movie as so many films were for a
while kids can enjoy the jokes and fight
scenes but they also have a lot of harsh
adult moments too including some pretty
intense violent imagery like I said they
earned that PG rating there's a lot of
gruesome deaths in this cartoon that was
originally meant for kids as well as a
lot of bleeding and you feel every
impact I always grab my arm every time I
see this
ah something you may know is a lot of
Batman movies miss is the art of the
mystery Batman is said to be the world's
greatest detective but there's very few
mysteries to solve in the films at least
none that the audience can figure out -
this is a legitimately good mystery with
clues twists and turns there's even a
clever curveball thrown in if you check
the credits after the film and see who
did the phantasms voice I can't give it
away without revealing the phantasms
identity but let's just say it's a very
subtle touch to play with your deduction
a little more with that said there's
also a lot of mystery that's not
revealed I feel like the past couple
films with Batman have been showing too
much of how everybody does everything
but part of the fun is again it's a
comic book and there's a fun mystery to
how characters pull things off in comics
we never figure out how the phantasm
disappears and reappears in that puff of
smoke but we know it has to be an
illusion similar to how Batman sneaks
away when nobody is looking the same
with the Joker and how well-timed his
death traps are translated very well
into the cinematic universe it's also
suspenseful there's a chase scene
between Batman and a SWAT team that gets
pretty intense it just beats him down
further and further until he's totally
exposed I can't recall so many people
getting so close to seeing who Batman is
it's pretty damn hard padding well it
does big scenes like that well it also
does a great job at the little touches
like there's a scene where one of
Bruce's ex-girlfriends is about the hand
is asked to always flirting with other
women but see if he knows a little
foreshadowing in the scene what about
the I love the I word engagement I'd
watch out for Brucie if I were you girls
did you hear that that little glass
breaking well it's not her as that she's
about to well throw it as face but it's
clearly a little touch signaling that
something bad is going to happen
something is uncomfortable something is
just a little off little touches like
that are all over the place even to the
reveal of certain people's identities
and they just make the experience all
the more engaging when you watch it both
the first or second time and speaking of
sound everyone always glorifies the
music in the Batman movies and
rightfully so once again the music here
is amazing the way
surely Walker who did the music for the
animated series as a size and weight to
this that makes the epicness leap off
the screen her music was already great
but now with the budget they had she was
able to bring a gigantic choir in
complementing the gothic scope that
Batman deserves just try listening to
this without getting chills
it might even had the best moment of fat
man first putting on his mask you don't
even see what he looks like but the
music guarantees you it's the coolest
thing you can imagine
calm
it also helps create what many consider
the biggest Joker laughs ever again
without giving too much away it's the
climax of the movie everybody is
bloodied and beaten up and they just
find out the entire place is about to
blow everyone thinks their number is up
and there's no way out as explosions
bursts into the air fire consumes the
sky and our ki and chaos is everywhere
acquiring Latin is screaming into the
night and the Joker lets out what could
possibly be his last laugh it's as epic
as you could possibly get
so this movie seems to be everything
Batman the comics the cartoons the TV
shows the movies so how come it doesn't
get more attention well there's a few
theories one is the marketing wasn't
very good it was as generic advertising
as you could get it just showed them
punching some guys the Joker says a line
we see a bit the phantasm and that was
it I don't know why so little effort was
put into it especially when marketing
for the Batman movies has always been
very impressive even for the bad ones
maybe it was because of fairy 2 there
just wasn't that much respect for
animation if it didn't have Disney's
name on it some critics didn't even get
a chance to review it Siskel and Ebert
went out of their way to do a special
episode talking about the movie as they
didn't get to review it when it first
came out but they want to draw attention
to it on video and felt it didn't
deserve to fly under the radar my Batman
animated feature that was made in 1993
and Roger Knight never reviewed it and
as far as I'm concerned we made a big
mistake because it's terrific
another theory is that while it did take
a few risks it didn't take enough to
leave a big enough impact everyone
remembers Batman because it was so dark
and different everyone remembers Batman
and Robin because it was so can't being
lame everyone remembers Dark Knight
because it was so adult and disturbing
none of these are perfect movies but
they did take chances that you would
remember phantasm didn't really do that
much different aside from there being a
new character it just did Batman but
it's just the thing
it wasn't Nolan's Batman or Burton's
Batman or Snyder's Batman it was Batman
any part of this movie you can
immediately identify as something
familiar something you grew up with and
something you're still drawn to even as
an adult and that's what makes Batman
last for so long this movie came out
before Batman Forever came out and
diehard fans were shocked to see how
much more adult the version for kids was
than the version that was supposed to be
for adults
thank God we'll never have that happen
again
in a sense I can understand the argument
for not taking quote-unquote enough
risks I mean don't get me wrong people
still die in this and an animated film
that was PG with not seen as profitable
back then but I do personally kind of
like Batman and Dark Knight more for the
huge leaps and bounds they took it's
just gonna speak to me a little more but
in terms of which movie understands who
Batman is in all his reincarnations and
all the various versions that have been
out there all rolled into one
this really is it it has great drama
it has great comedy it has great acting
it has great writing it has great
artwork and it's totally faithful to its
source material while also introducing
new elements I'm always gonna have a
soft spot for these two but if you were
to ask me which film represents Batman
the best it's clearly this one it's deep
in complex but it's still gadgets and
costumes it's dark and grim but it still
has bright colors and visuals it's silly
enough for kids to have fun but smart
enough for adults to take seriously in a
long line of Batman's that always seemed
to go from one extreme to another this
seems like the perfect in-between it's
it's own thing while also being a
continuation of what we know and love it
works on pretty much every level so the
next time somebody asks who's your
favorite movie Batman along with Keaton
and Affleck maybe throwing comma in
there along with Nicholson and Ledger
maybe consider Hamill because this is
not only a legitimate Batman film it's
the best one done and stuff just
shrugging it off as just the cartoon
movie maybe it should be considered as a
better representation than some of the
ones we're getting today and if somebody
tells you that movie is nothing more
than kids stuff
just remember Batman was seen as kid
stuff too but those who look deeper find
something they'll last much longer into
adulthood
I'm a nostalgia credit guy remember so
you don't have coming next week it's old
versus new of Cinderella live-action vs.
animated but you can see it now under
vessels ad free early access just three
dollars a month to see tons of people's
videos early as well as a bunch of other
extra features check it out and get the
early scoop
hey this is dog walker doing the charity
shout-out this week we are doing the
Children's Tumor foundation this is a
not-for-profit organization dedicated to
finding effective treatments for the
millions of people worldwide living with
neurofibromatosis also known as NF n F
causes tumors to grow on nerves
throughout the body this can lead to
blindness bone abnormalities cancer
deafness learning disabilities and an
incredible amount of pain NF affects one
in every 3,000 people
the Children's Tumor Foundation funds
critical research into finding a cure as
well as better ways to treat it in
addition to benefiting those who live
with NF this research is shedding new
light on several forms of cancer brain
tumors and learning disabilities
there's even an NF Awareness Month where
people run marathons and just overall
spread the word about what a terrible
disease this is both their site and
their YouTube channel have so many
inspiring stories of people that have
had to live with this and the incredible
struggle that they've gone through
definitely go check them out here their
tales and see what a difference you can
make in somebody's life
you